Hello everyone and welcome to another
video. Now today we're testing the new
AMD Radeon RX 960 XT. This comes in two
flavors, an 8 and 16 gigabyte model. I
have the 16 gig model here, more
specifically the Asus Prime OC Edition,
kindly provided by Asus for purposes of
review. This is an almost all black
triple fan design. No RGB here. I really
like the look of this card. a big fan of
simple yet sleek designs such as this.
It has a single eightpin power connector
and three display connectors, two
display ports, and one HDMI up at the
front. This model also has a P and Q
mode or performance and quiet BIOS mode.
And we'll be using it in the default
performance mode, of course, for today's
benchmarking. Now, in this initial
video, I'll be testing 20 games at 1440p
resolution. We'll be expanding on FSR
and RAID tracing. Later on in the week,
I'll feature a couple of tests here
today, but the main focus will be 1440p
native performance. Starting with
Blackmmith
Wong. Now, man, ran out of hard drive
space. So, this is the benchmark
version. This is the only benchmark run
you're going to see in this video. But
the first thing that I noticed was the
high clock speed over 3 GHz. I don't
think I've ever seen a GPU clock this
high. I have it paired with an i712700F
and 32 gigs of DDR5 today. Nothing too
fancy, but hopefully it's more
representative of a realworld build for
this type of card. A good start then
with Blackmith Wukong at over 60 fps on
average at 1440p medium. Now for Call of
Duty Black Ops 6, I went with the
extreme preset. Now, you're probably
going to want lower than this because
this is an online competitive title and
the more frames the better. But I
thought, you know what, let's stick it
on extreme. see what sort of frame rates
we get at this resolution, and I'm
pleased to say that we saw over 100
frames pers with these visual settings.
Now, the footage you're seeing is from a
bot match, a free-for-all bot match on
one of my favorite maps from back in the
Black Ops 1 days. This is firing range.
Of course, performance will differ
depending on the map, but I think it's
safe to say you're going to get decent
frame rates no matter which game mode or
map you are playing with the 1960 XT. As
you can see, even in pairing with an
i712700F, it's still a decent CPU, don't
get me wrong, but you're probably going
to see this car tested with uh far more
higherend offerings. So, I wanted to
test with something a little more
affordable, but something that can still
allow a card like this to stretch its
legs. Now, you can tell the immediate
difference between a bot match and
online play because here in CS2, I'm
getting demolished at basically every
few seconds. The average was over 200
frames pers. However, the game looks
really good with the high preset, which
it defaulted to when I fired it up. Now,
in terms of power, the card seems to
peak at about 175 W. This ASUS Prime OC
model that is. And as for the clock
speed, we've mentioned it before, you're
going to often see over 3 GHz. Well,
pretty much all of the time. And in CS2,
it's another solid result here. I just
hope pricing holds firm. And if not, if
you can't find it or it's way too
expensive, there's always used 7700 XTs,
which I've seen a lot of comparisons to
in the few reviews that I've watched
already. Of course, that will offer less
VRAM and won't be as capable when it
comes to ray tracing, something we'll
touch on later. Now, for Cyberpunk 2077,
we'll start off with 1440p and the
higher preset along with high crowds and
the default anti-aliasing solution. This
does have the choice of FSR, but that
was actually disabled here. Even at
native, I just used the um default
anti-ync solution that the game comes
with here. And this gave us 81 FPS on
average at 1440p. The 1% low was 62 and
the.1% low was 55. So it was a pretty
consistent experience in and around this
busy downtown area. Instead of covering
it at the end, which I was originally
going to do, I'm going to talk about ray
tracing as well. Now, in the games that
I actually tested it, I've only got a
couple because it's something I want to
expand on later on in the week. Uh, but
Cyberpunk 2077 with ray tracing for at
least 60 fps. You're probably going to
want 1080p. I wouldn't really say this
is the sort of card that you're going to
want to enable ray tracing with a lot of
the time. It is, of course, down to
personal preference, but if you want to
play with ray tracing with the 960 XT in
Cyberpunk, well, we can still use RT
Ultra, but we're going to need FSR3
quality. This will give us 79 frames per
second, a 1% low of 62, and a.1% low of
49. Now, with FSR off, we were looking
at less than 60 FPS as an average, which
is fine, of course, if you're happy with
that, but worth pointing out that for
plus 60, we're going to need to
implement some form of upscaling for
this one. Doom: The Dark Age is up next
at 1440p. Of course, I should stop
saying that because all of the games
were tested at 1440p today. Well, apart
from the occasional raid tracing test
and those situations where we may have
had to
upscale anyway, we'll get on to that a
little later on with Oblivion
Remastered, but for now, Doom: The Dark
Ages, medium preset, and TIA gave us 60
frames per second as an average. There
were a few dips and drops below that as
you can see here, dipping to the mid to
low 50s, but all in all, performance, I
think, was okay here. This is one of the
more intensive titles for the 960 XT
that we've tested today. Now, I've
included Elden Ring as more of a
consistency test because it is kept at
60 frames pers by default here. And we
were able to achieve that with the
maximum graphical preset. That said,
rate tracing was turned off because that
gave us a lot more dips and drops, but
the average overall was 60. The 1% low
frame rate was 55 and the.1% low was 31.
I'll also mention the temperature and
not just here where we've got an FPS
cap, but in other titles as well, it
rarely exceeded 50s or the low 50s in
terms of uh degrees C according to the
MSI After Burner overlay. Anyway, I
certainly think we could have pushed for
Horizon 5 a little higher. This is
1440p, of course, with the ultra preset
and TAA. I think we could have gone with
the extreme mode here um because we saw
165 FPS with the ultra preset, a 1% low
of 142 and a.1% low of 137. Now,
personally, as someone who lives in
Britain, uh I do prefer Forza Horizon 4.
I prefer the setting, and I also enjoy
the smaller file size as well. It takes
up a lot less hard drive space, but I do
like Forza Horizon 5 as well, just
firing up and driving around sometimes.
And it's nice to know that it runs
really well on the 960 XT. Runs well on
a wide range of hardware, but there are
certainly no issues here. And in terms
of consistency, it's pretty much
flawless. Now, when it comes to GTA 5,
the legacy version is still more popular
according to the Steam most played
chart, but I like to test the enhanced
version because I think the graphical
upgrades are really nice, especially
with the higher RT settings enabled.
Like here we're using very high, the
very high RT preset. Uh in fact with
FSR3 enabled and set to native
resolution, so native 2560 x440, this is
one of my favorite times of day in the
game. In some places, the lighting can
be a bit more subtle, but with RTGI or
Ray trace global illuminations on, yeah,
there are some really standout zones,
and I think this is one of them. I've
just stolen a bus and I did attempt to
drive it off the end of the pier, which
wasn't very nice to all the remaining
passengers, but I failed epically and
ended up getting wiped out by my own bad
driving. Overall, we're seeing at least
80 frames per second with the very high
RT preset. Maximum RT did give us drops
below 60 frames per second. I think we
averaged around that as well. So, the
very high RT preset is a better bet with
this GPU. Hell Divers 2 up next with the
high preset here. Nothing else changed
for 84 frames per second, a 1% low of
80, and a 0.1% low of 51. Just running
around the planet like a maniac,
shooting at anything that moves here.
Performance was pretty good. There was
the odd spike in the frame time graph,
but nothing really all that noticeable.
And performance overall, yeah, was
decent. As you can see, temperature of
the card sitting at around 50°. Didn't
really exceed that. And if it did, it
really wasn't by much. I think I
mentioned that earlier with the Elder
Ring test, too. Keep an eye on the VRAMm
usage and utilization as well. Kingdom
Come Deliverance 2 will run with at
least 60 frames per second at the ultra
preset. I'm not sure I can say as much
for the experimental preset. I didn't
test it, but I found that setting things
to high made more sense because it gave
us a bit more headroom. It still looks
absolutely fantastic. This is with
SMA2TX enabled as well. 79 FPS overall
with a 1% low of 70 and a.1% low of 68.
So, not only is the average pretty
decent, but the consistency is nice as
well. Keep an eye on the VRAMm uh usage
and utilization throughout today's
video. Here you can see uh we're
encroaching on that or exceeding now
that 8 gigs of VRAM. So, if we had the 8
gig card, well, at these settings, it
would be interesting to see what the
differences are and if I can get my
hands on the 8 gig version, I'll be
testing it and comparing it. It's about
$50 cheaper in terms of the MSRP. So
hopefully it's about the same price-wise
here in the UK, 50 quid cheaper. If you
can't stretch the extra, then it may be
worth it if you're playing at lower
resolutions, 1080p, but I can't really
say much until I've tested it. Um, if
you can't afford the extra, of course,
then you know, you're going to want to
know whether or not that card is
suitable. I don't want to sit here and
just say I'll spend the extra because
let's say your budget's maxed out with
the 8 gig card. You're going to want to
know how it performs. So yeah, we'll be
testing that soon. Left 4 Dead 2 is up
next. This is the farm level. I know
it's an older game, but I wanted to test
it because it can still put some
hardware through its paces, especially
when we max out all the settings like
we've done here. 8x MSAA with the
highest visual options. Of course, the
960 XT is handling this with ease at
over 200 frames pers and solid
percentile lows, too, with 151 and 110.
I really enjoy this level. Something
jumped out at me just before I started
recording. So yeah, it's a shame I
didn't capture my reaction really, but
performance-wise running pretty well
here. For Spider-Man 2, I decided to
implement FSR4. Now, this is of course
something we can do with the 9000 series
cards. And to do it, we just enable it
from the Radeon Relive software. It just
overrides the default version. So when
we choose the graphical settings with
Spider-Man, it'll actually say FSR4. We
can also check that it's enabled in
game. I didn't turn on any of the
presets, quality, performance, or
balanced. I left it at native. So, this
is FSR4 native. 2560 x440 looks nice and
crisp. I didn't feel the need to enable
quality mode. Uh I felt that the 82 FPS
average was pretty decent, but there
will still be a few dips and drops below
60 uh when using these settings. I
wanted to try Atom Fall next. I really
enjoy this game, and with the ultra
preset at 1440p, we're looking at 74 FPS
on average. I think this is a fantastic
looking game as well. Takes place in the
British countryside. The British
countryside, sorry. And it runs really
nicely. Not only that, but the
consistency is solid, too. We're looking
at 64 FPS as that 1% low and 63 as
that.1% figure. So, not only does it run
with at least 60 frames per second, but
it's super smooth on the 960 XT. Next
up, we'll test the original Red Dead
Redemption, which has a 144 FPS cap. And
of course, the 960 XT had no issues
hitting this. Our average was in fact
144. This is with FSR3 enabled as the
anti-aliasing solution and set to
native. That said, there were a few dips
and drops below this in certain areas,
but this didn't affect the average. I
think this is a really good looking
game. Of course, it came out on consoles
years ago and it still looks good on the
original PS3 as far as I'm concerned,
too. So, on PC with the extra graphical
options, I think it still looks pretty
decent and um yeah, it's still one of my
favorite games to be fair. So, here we
are. The dreaded Oblivion Remastered. I
thought this was another good
opportunity to test FSR4. As I said
before, we just enabled it from the
Radon Relive software, and we needed it
here because this is footage from
without it and the high preset. Even
dropping to the medium preset, we
couldn't hit 60 fps consistently. So, I
thought, why don't we enable FSR4
quality, it actually looks really good,
and it gave us a chance to test FSR4,
too. So, here with the high preset,
1440p with FSR4 quality, the game is
looking nice and sharp. And better yet,
our performance was improved. We're
looking at 71 frames pers. The 1% low
was 53 and the 0.1% low was 31. So still
a few issues, a few dips and drops which
I've come to expect from this one, but
it looks fantastic and it's running a
lot better now. It's also worth
mentioning again the VRAM usage. The 8
gig card would probably be struggling a
bit more, but I don't want to comment
too much until I've tested that, of
course. Next up, we shall try the
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt here. I've also
tested this one with ray tracing
enabled, but to start with, we're
looking at 1440p with the ultra preset
and SSR set to low with TAU for 127 fps.
SSR of screen space reflections were set
to low because this can knock a lot off
the average frame rate. So, I thought it
was better switched to low here. Though,
we were still getting plus 60 FPS with
it set to high. 127 was the average, the
1% low was 103, and the.1% low was 90.
If we switch to ray tracing, just like
in Cyberpunk, again, we're better suited
to 1080p. This is with the RT Ultra
preset and FSR2 balanced. Here we're
seeing 65 frames pers. So, we do need
FSR enabled in order to make use of the
full rate tracing feature set here. 65
FPS on average, 1% low of 54 and a.1%
low of 51. This was actually really
consistent with RT enabled. And it looks
really good, too. For Boulders Gate 3, I
went with the ultra preset and TAA here.
No issues. We're hitting at least 100
FPS. 109 was the average in and around
the city here. The 1% low was 70. No,
sorry, 80. And the.1% low was 46. I
think a sudden frame dip was responsible
for this.1% low. As I was exploring the
city here, I wanted to try Dead Island 2
next because I picked this up as part of
an Epic Store sale. And by sale, I mean
it was free on the Epic Store not long
ago, so I downloaded it. I've been
playing it a little bit with the high
preset at 1440p. It runs with 114 FPS,
but there are a few little dips and
drops here and there. For the most part,
though, looks great and runs quite well.
Our penultimate game today is Fortnite.
Now, for this one, I selected the high
preset, and this enabled lumen, high,
and nanite, which I just left on by
default. I also selected taa for the
anti-aliasing solution here. Now, just
like in Call of Duty and CS2, you may
want to turn things down a bit because
this is an online competitive title and
the more frames the better. But I
thought, let's see how well it handles
it with these graphical settings. And
quite well, I think is the answer. 99
FPS overall, 1% low of 81, and.1% low of
54. So overall, it looks quite nice and
it runs fairly well, too. So to
finalize, we have Red Dead Redemption 2.
And I'm going to revisit this one later
in the week because for some reason it's
performing well on average and it's
looking great. 75 fps with ultra and taa
high but the 1 and.1% lows are quite
low. 47 or 41. And if you look at the
frame time graph there's a little spike
in it every so often. But all in all
there we have the 9060 XT. Hopefully
we're looking at a decent price, decent
stock as well. And all that's left to
say is thank you very much for watching.
This has been my 20 game 1440p benchmark
test with this new card. Really enjoying
my time with it so far. I'll have more
FSR4 tests in the week. More RA tracing
tests if that's something you want to
see. Be testing a few individual games.
Red Dead Redemption 2 comes to mind as
well. Let me know your thoughts down
below because I'd love to read your
comments. And as always, let me know the
pricing and availability, what it's like
where you live, because this card should
start appearing when I upload this
review as well. So, what's left to say
is thank you very much for watching. If
you enjoyed this one, leave a like,
leave a dislike if you didn't, subscribe
to the channel if you haven't done so
already, and you want to, of course, and
hopefully I'll see all of you in the
next one.